you know one thing i want to get back to
just thinking yeah
um your point about getting out of angel
list you know for a while during the
apple
thing with with apple and hay i was
actually considering if if the apple
decision would have gone the other way i
was considering quitting
and basically retiring you as a like
yes because here's why
if i didn't get into business i didn't
start a business to be told what to do
by another business
right no you don't want to be bullied no
and not even bullied just like
yeah bullied you're right bullied i
don't want to be like that's not why i'm
an independent like i've i've
we've built an independent business
intentionally we don't have outside
funding you know the whole story right
yeah we're self-funded we we do
everything our own way so we can do it
our own way
and to be in an industry where if apple
forced
us to have to give them 30 percent of
our business and not be able to
interface with our customers the way we
want i don't want to be in that industry
i'm not interested in
no it's running a business it's horrible
and like that's not if that's the norm
i want out i'm not interested in that so
like i was contemplating that
during the thing like i didn't know
where this was going to go we truly
didn't know and by the way i will say at
the end when it all kind of came
together
apple was very gracious and they gave me
a phone call and explained that
yeah i mean it was it was nicely handled
in the end um and
and the fellow i can't share his name
but the fellow who i was interacting
with at apple
was a very fair-minded kind person he
was just doing his job
right you know he wasn't being able to
he wasn't the one making the ultimate
calls here
um and he gave me a call at the end to
let us know the app was finally approved
and i was really happy with how that all
wrapped up but
for a while there i'm like i don't want
to do this anymore i don't want to be in
this industry if i have to basically
give in to a
trillion dollar if a trillion dollar
business can tell me how to run my
business an independent business worth
whatever it's worth it doesn't even
matter it's nowhere near what apple's
worth
if i can't be myself i can't run my own
company my own way what's the point in
business at all no it'd be like you know
what if
you think about the art and the
craftsmanship the
the the craft work that we do making
these companies
it would be like being in the movie
business and like you make this great
film and the theaters are
just like yeah no you can't be on the
screen it's like
but i put all this effort and art into
this and like you have the movie theater
and i have the movie like can we get
along
and this is why i think you know the i'm
not a big regulation guy
um i like free markets i think you do
like free markets
but this is anti-competitive and when
you when
when a company gets so big they need to
become self-aware
and they have to pick the battle and
they have to figure out
is this the hill they want to die on or
the hill they want to murder people on
and it's a stupid decision for apple
to to pick that hill to die on they got
here by developers
they don't make good software apple
makes terrible software
apple every apple product would
you know from video editing to audio
editing to calendar to mail sucks
they're dependent on the ecosystem to
make beautiful apps
so why antagonize people who want to be
on your platform and i think that's what
they realized and i think it's a very
important thing for people listening to
this podcast to realize is
when there is injustice like this with a
big company speak up
write the blog posts and the other
founders the other podcasters the other
entrepreneurs are going to rally
behind you yeah we saw a lot of that and
and it gave us a lot of energy because
this was really an argument we were
making for all developers not i mean we
were using our
we were in the thick of it so like this
is our example but this we want to see
rule changes for everybody because it's
simply just not fair and here's the
other thing you know
we heard from so dozens and dozens of
founders and and entrepreneurs and
and developers who came out of the
woodwork privately to us off the record
so yeah they're not going to say it
publicly
yeah they're afraid and when you're
afraid when when a company strikes fear
in other
that's the task yes that's the tell that
something is wrong here
and there's so many companies out there
and independent developers who feel
totally
bullied have been pushed around and
strong armed by large companies apple
included
and but they're afraid they're afraid
and you basically have
historically you've had to have been
spotify or
netflix or some big massive company who
can
spend the time and spend the money
arguing right the thing is is that
company like
the public doesn't care about billion
dollar companies arguing with each other
i think what was interesting about this
case is that we were a relatively small
company
arguing against the big company and that
was kind of i think where the leverage
was
ultimately and i and i'm i'm glad that
it happened and i'm glad that there's
some rule changes we'd love to see a lot
more and i think your idea also is good
there's a lot of great ideas out there
and i think i'm hopeful that that apple
will begin
over time over the next few years to
begin to pry open the door a little bit
and give some people some choice and
some options
otherwise at some point and who knows
when this is going to be because no
company really knows when this happens
until it flips
yeah people are going to leave or
governments are going to come down even
harder and we'll see how the eu shakes
out and there's also an anti-trust
investigation starting the u.s i think
in july this month here so you overplay
your hand at your peril you know you
really have to think it through if
you're going to be a bully
like this all of those enemies
accumulate and
you know the same exact thing happened
when i started criticizing google
um people were like hey jay cal let it
go
you know just take the loss lay off your
employees and
and don't fight it i was like that's not
how i'm going down i'm going down
swinging
and to this day i say matt cut screwed
me and i say they lied to me and i think
that there should be antitrust
because if you look at what they did
with search
they this is the the lying was so
obvious they said we didn't change
organic search
and i'm like okay but you moved the
first organic search result
400 pixels down the goddamn page and you
put your box ahead of it
yeah so you and everybody knows
that 90 of the clicks are on the first
three choices
therefore putting yelp down there
therefore putting travel therefore
putting mahalo whatever it is down there
you put yourself up top you don't have
to change the organic results you're
lying and you caught them in this lie
and
if you think about this bad behavior
you know when people are scared of
speaking up
that should make you yourself have
some level of self-reflection and this
is what i told to the
highest levels of google um i said
do you really want people to be scared
of you
is that how you want to live your life
right because
you could also be gracious and generous
and you're making how much money has to
pile up in apple's coffers
for them to think it's worth it you know
like
what point do you just look in the
mirror and hate yourself
it's it's bad it is baffling and it's
unfortunate but i think sometimes what
happens is that not to defend it because
i'm with you on this completely is that
just
this is what happens public markets
demand returns and they they're look
everyone's looking for money and
everyone's looking for revenue and
there's a big revenue source and they
can take a slave you want to take a
slice of every apple
take a slice of every service that
exists like you could see how they would
want that
their whole their service business now
so you can just kind of see how these
things evolve
it doesn't mean that there's bad people
that are making these decisions it's
just like
this is this is what this is what
happens yeah and
as as a company amasses more and more
and more power this is what happens this
is just what
happens every single time um and at some
point it breaks and by the way
speaking of google i mean you know
probably was it last year
we got a whole thing with google around
having to buy our own branded keywords
because at google's selling our branded
keywords other people and
so they made the ads look like organic
results even more so than ever before
and people don't know and people are
confused and it's
brutal it's brutal like why why i could
tell you how we could fix this this is
what we need to do because i did this
with mahalo
i recorded people using google if you
record people using google
and you say and you show them those
[ __ ]
ads where they make you pay to
not have your competitor there so for
you you know
if base camp is being competed against
by acme project management
they can buy your keyword yeah put
themselves up there then you have to buy
it
the the word ad is a little tiny chiclet
and if you the smallest you could
possibly do it if you
have a hundred people do it and then
afterwards say did you click on an ad
or did you click on an organic search
result
they will say i didn't click on an ad 60
70 percent of the time it's been
proven for sure and if there were videos
like that submitted
to the eu and we just did a focus group
it cost a thousand dollars to do this
if you're listening to me and you've got
a problem with this and you do all you
have to do is run that test and then
google
will stop in their tracks because the
last thing they want to do is get in a
fight
with people who say you're deceiving
users
right and it's so clear they're
deceiving users by making the
ad look so similar remember the old days
the ad was in a box with a color behind
it totally is light blue and in fact if
you look at like i think the new york
times maybe did a piece on the stage
looked at like
google ads over the last 10 years or
something maybe it's the post i'm not
sure who it was now
but anyway and you could see that
there's been a conscious effort
to make these things look more and more
and more like organic results more
native yeah
and it's it's just it's wrong and here's
the other thing that's so wrong about it
is that
google will allow anyone to buy our
trademarked brand name basecamp
okay or hey um i haven't even looked at
hey ads i don't know if anyone's taking
ads i can say yeah but anyway
um but if you try to buy google and put
google in your app yeah no they will say
no no you can't use google that's a
trade that's registered trademark so
they know the value of the brand they
know the value of trademarks
and their argument would be well we
can't have a database of everyone's
trade what do you mean you have a
database of everything
yeah you just index the world's data
that's your argument right
yeah that's your argument it's like
facebook being like we can't figure out
what
you know the posts are about hate speech
or porn but they
can figure out if you put a dating ad
app like they can't figure out it's a
russian or racist ad
yeah but the second you put a competing
social network ad up or a competing
you know uh ad for a a dating site
you're immediately taken down it's like
really guys yeah
i mean you've got the brightest people
brightest people in the world working
these places of course they can do this
it's just about the will
and and the business model and all that
so i mean of course they can fix that so
it's really frustrating though and it's
it's sad that there's basically duopoly
you've got google you've got apple
you've got these massive companies that
exerting all this pressure on the mobile
environment there's no one else
there's no other mobile operating
systems windows phone's gone
there's two and they basic google's
slightly better in the in their app
store or google play store is slightly
better with these rules but
they're gonna move in apple's direction
too i think and they're already kind of
maybe doing it i don't know
but also like you said it doesn't really
matter i want the absolute i want the
apps reviewed and so what i think
you know to my point before about like
hey i'm gonna put mine on experimental
mode
or you know i'm gonna
put it in developer mode basically
anybody can click it over to developer
mode and do whatever they want with
their phones
i like the idea that they're reviewed i
like apps being reviewed for
you know malware or whatever but i might
want to take a risk
on you know something which is you know
they i think they were going to try to
kill test flight before they bought it